[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I'm really
excited to show you
how AppSheet uses intent
AWARE AI to help quickly
automate business processes.
Timely order processing
is key to any business.
But it frequently involves
various systems, manual steps,
and waiting for approvals.
AppSheet automation
helps solve THIS
by enabling anyone on the team
to quickly and intelligently
automate a process.
Let's look at the platform.
The [INAUDIBLE] platform
anticipates your automation
requirements, provides
intelligent suggestions,
and auto-constructs actions,
based on user intent.
It's super easy to
create a new automation.
Process steps can be
described in plain English,
starting to type "approval"
prompts contextual suggestions.
Steps can be quickly added to
monitor your business process,
and details can be added
later, or picked for you.
Let's fast forward to the
last step in the process.
Let's add a final step to send
the invoice to the customer.
The platform already
generates the invoice,
highlights possible
recipients, and even
auto-fills relevant
details for you.
Great, we are done
building our process.
Now, let's see this
automation in action.
As a new order gets
added in Salesforce,
our process is triggered.
Since it's a high
value order, it's
sent to the manager
for approval.
The manager gets the push
notification on the device.
The order details are
reviewed and approved
by the manager instantly
from the approvals app.
Rich approval
applications can be built
in minutes using AppSheet.
The order is then routed to
the warehouse for fulfillment,
and the ops team gets
notified via Google Chat.
Finally, an invoice
for this order
is automatically
emailed to the customer.
Automating your business
processes made easy.
AppSheet automation brings
together the power of AI
and [INAUDIBLE] in a unified
platform for building rich apps
and powerful automation
within minutes,
so you can innovate faster.